Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Andre.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Hä?
Hier dreht sich alles im Kreis. Äh ich wollte jetzt hier eigentlich ein bisschen überraschen damit, aber äh jetzt hast du's gleich ausgepetzt. Wir sind heute zu dritt, denn die Themenlage dachten wir uns,
rechtfertigt eine leichte Erweiterung unseres Gesprächskreises. Und von daher sind wir eben nicht nur Tim Pritla und Linus Neumann, wie wir es sonst sind, sondern wir begrüßen auch Andre,
Meister, hallo.
Hallo, im Internet auch als elf bekannt. Ilf, ILF.
Als Elf. Die elf, Entschuldigung.
Mit geschlossenem.
Datenschutz.
Genau, denn äh ja, die Themenlage äh hat sich etwas zugespitzt äh Dinge, die wir hier auch schon angesprochen haben,
Haben sich ein wenig entwickelt. Ähm wollen wir nicht lange um den heißen Brei herum reden, worum es geht,
ist die Funkzellen, Handyfunktion Überwachung, die von der wir ja vor kurzem noch ausführlich berichteten im Nachgang
zum Kongress zum achtundzwanzigsten Kongress, wo es ja einen langen Vortrag gab von ähm,
Über die Situation in Sachsen und so weiter,
und ja und jetzt gab's breaking News, publiziert Beinetzpolitik Punkt org und zwar genau von dir, Andre zum Thema.
Dass das Ganze auch hier in Berlin stattgefunden hat. Was ist denn so der.
Der äh der Exerp, was ist denn so das Management Samory der Situation.
Wir haben bei Netzpolitik ORG Akten bekommen ähm
in denen schriftlich steht, dass auch in Berlin im Jahre zwotausendneun eine sogenannte Funkzellenabfrage von der Polizei angefordert und in diesem Zuge vorgenommen wurde,
Das ist nicht überraschend für Leute, die sich tatsächlich intensiv mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung auseinandersetzen,
Aber jetzt haben wir das mal wieder schwarz auf weiß gehabt und konnten damit schöne Bilder machen, welche äh Gebiete von Friedrichshain das ungefähr betrifft,
noch visualisiert für alle anderen Fälle von Autobrandstiftungen, wie das denn aussehen könnte.
Bisschen Hintergrund dazu geschrieben, alle möglichen verantwortlichen Stellen angefragt, ob sie denn dazu eine Stellungnahme haben, länglichen Fragenkatalog, wie oft denn das gemacht wird, wie viele da äh Daten,
übermittelt werden so im Schnitt. Wie viele Personen davon betroffen worden sind, ob mal jemand informiert wurde,
leider innerhalb von zwei Wochen keine Antwort bekommen und dann haben wir das einfach mal gepostet auf Netzpolitik,
Und dann gab's einen recht großes Medienecho, zumindest in der Hauptstadtpresse,
aufgegriffen, die ganzen Journalisten und auch einige Politiker waren anscheinend sehr überrascht, dass das nicht nur in Dresden passiert, sondern auch in Berlin,
Und ja, welche Ausmaße das annimmt.
Genau, also aus welchem Grund haben sie das gemacht? Ist gegen, du hast das kurz an erwähnt, um die Autobrände in Berlin.
Ist in diesem einen Fall, von dem wir die ursprüngliche Akte hatten, das wird natürlich nicht nur,
Zur Ermittlung bei Autobrandstiftungen genutzt, sondern auch bei mehreren anderen Deliktformen, wo sie uns aber noch immer noch keinen äh abschließenden Katalog vorgelegt haben, außer der, wo sie's machen dürfen, deren Gesetz steht.
Erhebliche.
Sind dann so auch Sachen wie Steuerhinterziehung und ähm.
Da ist natürlich eine Funkzellenabfrage, ein sehr probates Mittel.
Ja, da verwenden Verfassungswidriger Kennzeichen und so.
Also in dem konkreten Fall, den du jetzt untersucht hast, was hat die Polizei da gemacht? Die haben festgestellt, irgendwo wurde versucht ein Auto anzuzünden,
und dann haben sie sich von allen Funkzellen, die da irgendwie,
diesen Bereich irgendwie äh versorgen würden, also was weiß ich, von den verschiedenen Providern, um diesen Bereich irgendwie verteilte Funkzellen, davon alle Daten geben lassen, was die zu einem in einem gewissen Zeitraum wert
in dieser Funkzelle eingeloggt war und sie genutzt hat.
Genau, die Polizei ist zum Tatort gegangen, hat geguckt, welche Funkzellen sind da zu empfangen,
hat die aufgeschrieben und dann über den Weg Staatsanwaltschaft Gericht, an die Provider gegangen, die dann die äh,
Verkehrsdaten derjenigen Mobilfunkgeräte herausgegeben hat, die,
in einem Zeitrahmen vor bis nach dem Tatzeitrahmen,
ähm dort kommuniziert haben. Das war irgendwie vor dem Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung sechs Stunden davor, bis eine Stunde danach,
quasi in dem einen Fall, den wir nachgeschoben haben, noch eine Akte, geschlagene acht Stunden und in dem ersten Fall, den wir ursprünglich publiziert haben, waren das fünfundsiebzig Minuten.
Wir noch nicht gesagt haben ist wann das alles wirklich stattgefunden hat. Also in welchem Jahr.
Die beiden Fälle, die wir publiziert haben, waren im Oktober und Juni zwotausendneun. Das findet aber nicht nur in den beiden Fällen statt, sondern immer noch bis heute.
Mhm. Das, woher wisst ihr das?
Weil ich gestern im Innenausschuss,
des Abgeordnetenhauses war und die Vizepräsidentin der Polizei das so gesagt hat, dass es rechtmäßig, wir machen das immer noch. Und auch seit dem Urteil zum Bundesverfassungsgericht haben die das hunderte Maler gemacht und Millionen Daten bekommen.
Wenn ich mich nicht täusche, hat die gute Dame da gesagt, dass es dreihundertsiebenundfünfzig Fälle gab insgesamt in Berlin,
Und insgesamt vier Komma zwei Millionen.
Datensätze dabei angefallen sind. Ungefähr das war jetzt die Zahl, die ich nach der Lektüre eines Artikels heute Morgen.
Die die genauen Fälle habe ich jetzt hier nicht drin. Das war gestern ein ganz schönes Zahlenstacato von der guten Frau Koppers hieß sie, glaube ich. Ähm,
in wie vielen Fällen,
klar ist, dass das der Bereich Staatsschutz des LKAs vier Komma zwei Millionen Verkehrsdaten seit zwotausendachtzehn der Vorratsdatenspeicherung angefordert hat, nur der Bereich Staatsschutz,
Ist das nicht mal das ganze LKA und das LKA ist noch nicht mal die gesamte Berliner Polizei.
Genau, diese Zahl, wie gesagt, dreihundertfünfundsiebzig stand heute in der Berliner Zeitung und dabei wurden, was sie dann gemacht haben, das haben sie also bei mehreren Brandstiftungen offensichtlich gemacht und dann haben sie geschaut, wer bei,
ähm wer bei mehreren, welche Handys, bei mehreren dieser Tatorte irgendwie vor Ort waren.
Sie haben gesagt, die haben das bei allen Autobrandstiftungen gemacht, wo sie eine Serientat vermuten,
wie auch immer die das konkret definieren, weiß ich nicht. Äh und dann auch gesagt,
gleichen die verschiedenen Daten der verschiedenen Fälle miteinander ab und gucken danach welche Mobilfunkengeräte an mehreren Tat,
Orten zur Tatzeit waren
und bei wahlweise vier oder fünf ähm Häufungen, wenn Mobilfunkgerät vier oder fünfmal in der Nähe des Tatorts war, wollten die dann gucken, so Zitat,
diejenigen, jeweilige Personen gute berufliche oder private Gründe hat am Tatort gewesen zu sein. Da konnte man dann mal genauer hingucken.
Was ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden habe, ist ähm,
Der Zeitraum, also die der Tatzeitpunkt, den du vorhin genannt hast oder die Zeitpunkt, den du vorhin genannt hast, waren das die Tatzeitpunkte oder waren das die Zeitpunkte, wo diese Anfragen gestellt wurden?
Das waren die Tat. Also es gibt eine Tatphase, wo die Polizei vermutet, dass innerhalb dieser Stunde der Vorgang wohl passiert wäre,
im Laufe der Ermittlungen, was Tage oder Wochen äh dauern kann
diese Zellen zu erheben und das alles aufzuschreiben, dann haben sie gesagt, wir wollen von den Providern sechs Stunden vor der Tatphase bis eine Stunde nach der äh Tatphase in diesem Zeitraum
Verbindungsdaten von allen Funktionen, die am Tatort zu empfangen sind.
Das heißt, die Anfrage, die dort eigentlich erfolgt ist, ist Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Das sind die Daten, die im Rahmen der Vorratsdatenspeicherung erhoben wurden, abgespeichert wurden, vorgehalten.
Grundsätzlich ja, den ursprünglichen, die ursprüngliche rechten ähm,
das ursprüngliche der Paragraph, den gibt es seit zwotausendeins, seit den rot-grünen Antiterrorgesetzen, aber tatsächlich,
Ist der in dieser Form, wie es den jetzt gibt, mit dem Paragraph hundert G Absatz zwei der Strafprozessordnung, erst seit dem Umsetzungsgesetz zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
und die Polizei hat gestern auch nur Zahlen geliefert, seitdem es die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt, zweitausendacht.
Das heißt, hätte es die Vorratsdatenspeicherung in der Form nicht gegeben? Hätten diese Daten auch so gar nicht erfragt werden können. Also wir reden jetzt nicht von einem Datenbestand, der auch sonst irgendwie angefallen wäre.
Das ist ein bisschen komplexer. Der Vorratsdatenspeicherung wurden die Telekommunikations äh Anbieter dazu verpflichtet, diese Daten für sechs Monate vorzuhalten,
Nachdem das Bundesverfassungsgericht das Urteil gesprochen hat, ist nur die Verpflichtung weggefallen,
die speichern das unterschiedlich lange weiter zwischen einer Woche bis zu sechs Monaten.
Ah, es gibt sozusagen kein explizites Verbot dieser Speicherung. Äh.
Naja das sagen.
Wenn die Provider jetzt, möchten sie quasi ihre eigene Vorratsdatenspeicherung weiter vorhalten können?
Na ja, es gibt ähm terressischen Bundesdatenschutzgesetz und die Provider dürfen das nicht länger speichern, als das entweder für die Rechnung,
Oder aber für den Erhalt des Mobilfunknetzes, für die Netzpflege, für die Sicherheit zulässig wäre,
Und das ist so deren Schlupfloch. Natürlich haben die jetzt einmal mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung
diese ganze Technik aufgebaut, diese ganzen Daten vorzuhalten, haben dort Millionenbeträge investiert und die Vorratsdaten Speicherung klebt ja wie ein Damenschwert über uns, wird ja wieder kommen
und die wollten das glaube ich nicht alles ähm wieder komplett irgendwie nach Deaf Null schieben,
sondern gucken, das kommt wieder, also können wir es auch erstmal so lassen.
Außerdem hätten die diese Daten gerne zu ihrer Netzverbesserung für Statistiken, in welchen Funkzellen waren, wie lange welche Handys eingeloggt und so. Das ist ganz nett für die. Ähm tatsächlich brauchen die für Rechnungsdaten,
nicht den Ort, wo ein Handy war,
oder Wäschemobilfunknummer mich angerufen hat oder mir eine SMS geschickt hat. Genau das wird aber in diesen Daten mitgespeichert und auch abgefragt. Es gibt
die dazu aufrufen, gegen diese Praxis zu klagen, die das für illegal und ein Verstoß gegen das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz halten. Ähm,
Derzeitige Praxis ist aber, diese Daten werden weiterhin auch ohne Gesetzespeicherung,
zwischen einer Woche und sechs Monaten gespeichert und die Behörden wissen das auch. Die wissen auch, wie lange das bei den jeweiligen Mobilfunk Provider gespeichert wird und wissen dann auch, ich muss mich beeilen, das geht nur dreißig Tage. Oder ja, können wir mal der da, der speichert eh ein halbes Jahr.
Das heißt, allein dadurch, dass es einmal dazu gekommen ist, Vorratsdatenspeicherung war gültig und aktiv und die
Provider mussten gehorchen haben, die sich die entsprechende Technologie zugelegt. Danach wurde die Vorratsdatenspeicherung zumindest weitgehend eingeschränkt, also zumindest in der Form untersagt. Alle gehen mehr oder weniger davon aus. Das Thema ist noch nicht komplett ausgeschwitzt, weil es wurde ja nicht vollständig verboten, sondern nur Auflagen
gestellt, wo es jetzt noch keine Neuregelung gibt, aber in dem Zusammenhang
wird diese Technik einfach weiter betrieben, das heißt die Fähigkeit selber Daten auf Vorrat abzulegen ist ohnehin da. Die Investition ist gemacht, die Provider können das jetzt einfach nutzen, weil niemand es ihnen verbietet.
Ja, ist auch nochmal ein interessanter Punkt ist und jetzt sind die Daten da und jetzt kommt die Polizei hin und sagt, na ja
wir hätten jetzt trotzdem mal gerne die Daten, so wie sie die Vorratsdatenspeicherung
eigentlich erzeugt hätte, auch wenn's die jetzt so eigentlich gar nicht mehr gibt, aber da ihr das ja eh habt, weil ihr das ja eh speichert, weil ihr das ja eh toll findet, dann könnt ihr es uns ja auch,
und gibt's in dem Moment auch wirklich eine Verpflichtung, das was sie haben auch rauszugeben.
Ich bin kein Jurist, aber ich glaube, wenn,
ein Gericht, das anordnet, was ja in den von uns untersuchten Fällen immer passiert ist, dann ist es für die Provider sehr, sehr schwer, das nicht zu tun. Da müssen die, glaube ich, einen eigenen, guten Juristen und einen guten Grund haben, warum sie die nicht herausgeben würden.
Das heißt, wir haben's hier einfach mit einer de facto Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Nutzung einer Vorratsseitenspeicherung zu tun.
Eine Speicherung von Daten auf Vorrat, was ich erstmal als Vorratsdatenspeicherung definieren würde, auch wenn es jetzt nicht diese explizite EU-Richtlinie oder das deutsche Umsetzungsgesetz davon,
im äh Wort Sinn des Gesetzes bedeutet, aber es ist eine Speicherung von Daten auf Vorrat, ja.
Ja, krass. Jetzt hast du gesagt, das Echo war groß, ist das Echo nicht generell groß, wenn Netzpolitik äh org was berichtet.
Ja, das ist unsere kleine Blase im Netz. Also im Netz ist das Echo immer groß, aber das jetzt tatsächlich jede gedruckte Zeitung, ähm dass sogar bis zu Boulevard Medien, Berliner Kurier, BZ,
DE das aufgreifen und es auch,
nicht mal eine Woche später zu Tagesordnungspunkten in mehreren Ausschusssitzungen wird, das haben wir auch bei Netzpolitik org nicht oft.
Wann wurde jetzt äh das erste Mal das gemeldet? Wann von wann ist eure erster Blogpost zu dem Thema?
Wir haben den ersten Post letzten Mittwoch oder Donnerstag, Mittwoch glaube ich, um dreizehn Uhr online gestellt. Das war der neunzehnte erste.
Neunzehnte. Heute ist der vierundzwanzigste erste auch mal gebieten worden, immer das Datum zu sagen. Das tun wir jetzt hiermit,
Zweitausendzwölf genau, weil wir wissen ja, das wird ja auch alles in fünfhundert Jahren nochmal abgehört. Ähm so und auch heute ist äh genau,
Wir speichern deswegen auch auf Vorrat hier, damit das später auch entsprechend nachgeforscht werden kann. Ähm so, jetzt ist das Ding also fünf Tage alt,
heute war es auch wieder fett in den Zeitungen, habt ihr gerade berichtet, ich war noch nicht am Kiosk.
Ja, das ging letzte Woche los mit dem Medienecho, dass einige Politiker hin und her sich dazu geäußert haben. Gestern war im Abgeordnetenhaus in Berlin gleich zwei Sitzungen von äh Ausschüssen,
Das war immer um zehn Uhr der Innenausschuss, ähm wo das sofort mit äh auf die Tagesordnung gesetzt wurde.
Zuständig ist für Polizeifragen unter anderem.
Unter anderem genau, äh dort waren dann auch der Innensenator von Berlin und die amtierende Polizei Vizepräsidentin.
Der neue Innensenator Henkel, der CDU Mann, der jetzt gerade ja den Job überhaupt erst übernommen hat. Genau. Mhm.
Ja auch öfters mal gesagt habe, ich kann nichts für die Taten meines Vorgängers, aber der findet das trotzdem gut, er hätte das nicht anders gemacht,
Und die äh amtierende Polizeivizepräsidentin, Präsident gibt's derzeit nicht oder Präsidenten. Ähm die haben dort mehr oder weniger Rede und Antwort gestanden und das erste Mal tatsächlich Zahlen auf den Tisch gelegt,
Am Nachmittag war da noch der sogenannte IT Dut, der Ausschuss für IT und Datenschutz,
Da war ich leider nur äh kurz drin, während das Topic war, aber da war auch wieder der Landesdatenschutzbeauftragte, der auch schon morgens anwesend war und es ging auch um dieses Thema. Dann soll es wohl irgendwie auch nochmal in den Rechtsausschuss,
im Abgeordnetenhaus kommen, eventuell nochmal äh ins Plenum und dann am achten Februar, glaube ich,
in achten oder dreizehnten Februar auch nochmal im Rechtsausschuss des Bundestages Thema werden. Das aber schon eh wir das öffentlich gemacht haben.
Mhm.
Ja, das heißt, eigentlich stellen sich alle auf die Hinterbeine und sagen, was wollt ihr denn? Äh, schwere Straftaten, brennende Autos, kann leben gefährden, das sind ja wohl schwere Straftaten, ich weiß nicht genau, wie da die juristische Einordnung ist, von so etwas, aber das lässt sich sicherlich argumentieren.
Es wurde irgendwie argumentiert, auch jetzt hier Zitat aus diesem Berliner Zeitungsartikel, den ich heute Morgen zu meinem Bagel genossen habe, dass äh wenn so ein Auto nämlich dann, wenn der Tank explodiert und voll ist, dann kommt ein fünf Meter Feuerball,
deswegen äh ist das auch lebensgefährlich und also alles andere als Spaß. Ist es ja auch, wenn mein Auto abfackeln ist.
Ist lebensgefährlich. Auf jeden Fall, da gab's auch Fälle, wo Leute irgendwie in Autos geschlafen haben und so. Ich meine, das mag jetzt nicht immer die große Wahrscheinlichkeit sein, aber das ist jetzt auch nicht komplett ausgeschlossen. Und das Problem natürlich des Übergreifens, nicht nur auf andere Autos, sondern auch auf Häuser.
Genau, geht deshalb ja auch nicht darum, diese Tat der,
Auto an Brandstiftungen zu verharmlosen, sondern wenigstens diese Funkzellen abfragen, aber mal als Mittel der dem ja dann sehr viele Menschen, sage ich mal, zum Opfer fallen, wenigstens mal in Frage zu stellen.
Wir wollen das ja gar nicht bagatellisieren, nur die Vorratsdatenspeicherung wurde uns immer mit Terrorismus begründet.
Es geht darum, nachzugucken mit wem wahlweise die Hamburger Terrorzelle oder Beate Zschäpe oder wer auch immer telefoniert hat,
ähm vom Einzelfall ausgehend,
und um schwersten Terrorismus, so wie das die Innenpolitiker immer gesagt haben, um die Vorratszeitenspeicherung überhaupt zu legitimieren,
Wenn das aber erstmal in Kraft ist und das haben wir ja oft genug äh im Vorfeld betont, dann wird das auch für ganz andere Sachen eingesetzt. Es das wird zum Enkeltrick eingesetzt, also wenn jemand anruft, Oma, überweise mir mehr Geld,
ähm jetzt bei Brandstiftung,
aber auch in Dresden, wo das Beispiel sich auch bekannt, wo es irgendwie um Körperverletzung geht und das ist auch nur die Spitze des Eisbergs. Wir haben gestern nur die Zahlen vom Staatsschutz gehört, andere Abteilungen der Berliner Polizei und,
Polizeien und Geheimdiensten anderer Bundesländer und des Bundes tun das auch und ich niemand weiß genau für welche Straftaten,
aber Terrorismus ist das bisher nicht.
Das heißt, eigentlich bewahrheitet sich das, was so vorher immer gesagt wurde.
Dass nach dem Dammbruch das einfach bei jeder, dass es zum Regelfall wird, dass da eine volle Überwachung stattfindet.
Wenn die Daten einmal da sind, werden sie auch genutzt.
Jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, ob die anderen Vorhersagen auch eintreffen, nämlich äh vor allem die Vorhersage, dass das ja dann alles überhaupt gar nicht so viel bringen würde. Ähm jetzt ist das zweitausendneun gewesen. Die ganze äh Jagd nach Autoanzündern hat ja diese Stadt
Berlin äh bis,
Noch vor wenigen Monaten schweren Arten gehalten. Jetzt ist es so ein bisschen wieder raus aus den äh Medien. So richtig viele Ergebnisse äh gab's wohl nicht, oder?
Der wurde doch vor einiger Zeit irgend so ein gefrusteter Hartz-IV-Empfänger,
Wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Der ohne jegliche linksradikalen Erwägungen einfach weil er schlecht gelaunt war äh sich dieses Hobby zugelegt hatte Autos anzuzünden. Ich weiß nur nicht genau wie viele von diesen Fahrzeugen.
Also er war sicherlich nicht für alles äh äh verantwortlich, aber wohl für eine ganze Reihe. Ich habe das.
Soweit ich weiß über hundert.
Über hundert sogar.
Über einhundert.
Oha, das ist schon eine Menge. Okay, das heißt, nicht nur, aber vor allem gab's einen Täter, der jetzt aber durch diese nicht ausfindig gemacht wurde.
Ähm es hieß.
Einhundert Fälle, ich meine, wenn du das nun wirklich konsequent, man ist ja so, dass das Versprechen der Rasterfahndung seit Ende der siebziger Jahre in der Diskussion, dass man eben genau über solche, äh, dass man genau solche Fälle ja dann eigentlich feststellen müsste.
Gestern in der Innenaussitzung wurde gesagt, man hat zwar vier Komma zwei Millionen Daten gesammelt in den letzten fünf Jahren, man hat aber keinen einzigen Verdächtigen durch diese Daten gefunden. Die Daten haben mal absolut null Komma nichts gebracht. Zur Ermittlung von Verdächtigen.
Und das, obwohl neunhundertsechzig Mal quasi Personen,
tatsächlich identifiziert wurden. Also dieser Fall eingetreten ist, dass man sagt, okay, der war dann und dann in der Nähe dieser Brandstiftung, dann dann in der Nähe dieser Brandstiftung oder eben auch in anderen Fällen ist ja offensichtlich nicht nur bei Brand.
Neunhundertsechzig von vier Komma zwei Millionen haben Auffälligkeiten gezeigt, wo man gesagt hat, da wollen wir jetzt auch mal wissen, wer es ist.
Vier Komma zwei Millionen Mobilfunkanschlüsse, sondern Verkehrsdaten.
Bewegungsinformationen sozusagen so äh auf.
Wann, wo welches Handy kommuniziert.
Ein Auftreten von irgendwas, okay. Und weiß man auch, wie viele Teilnehmer damit jetzt sozusagen konkret.
Das wurde leider nicht gesagt. In Dresden waren das bei neunhunderttausend Verbindungsdaten,
knapp zweihunderttausend, irgendwie hundertsechzigtausend äh Anschlüsse, von denen sie dann aber auch mal ganz sportlich vierzigtausend Inhaber äh Adressen und Namen eingeholt haben.
Neunhunderttausend und dann hundertsechzigtausend, die dabei.
Das waren im ersten Artikel.
Das wäre so ein Faktor fünf Komma sechs, also.
Zweihundertsechzigtausend Rufnummern sogar.
Wenn man das jetzt mal auf die vier Komma zwei Millionen äh überschlägt.
Es sind zehntausende, das sind viele.
Also ich.
Ja, da sind theoretisch eine Millionen, wenn man das mal hochrechnet, aber das aber wie kennen die Daten nicht? Ich weiß nicht, was da drin steht.
Aber man kann sich ja die die Fläche anschauen. Also Drehst ist vielleicht nochmal deshalb ein Sonderfall, weil das ja auch ein Tag einer Demonstration war, an dem sicherlich viele der Demonstrationsteilnehmer äh auch auf jeden Fall ihr Mobiltelefon genutzt haben. Wenn man sich jetzt irgendwie Berlin anschaut, Andre, der Artikel ist ja sehr empfohlen, hat da ja genau diese
Open Street Map, dieses gemacht, wo die Zellen eingezeichnet sind und Berlin ist eine dichtbesiedliche Stadt, da kann man sich ja zumindest ein grobe
Vorstellung auch einfach von der Fläche machen und wie viel Personen sich da jeweils drin aufhalten.
Also es wurde gestern von der Polizei Vizepräsidentin auch gesagt, dass diese Funkzellenabfragen in der Tat über das gesamte Stadtgebiet verteilt,
stattgefunden haben, jeweils da, wo es eine Serienautobrandstiftung gab.
Natürlich gibt's Häufungen,
gibt da auch diese lustige Google Map, Google Maps, Overlay, brennende Autos DE und nehme ich dann auch mal visualisiert habe, was das hieße, wenn bei all diesen Orten eine Funkzellenabfrage gemacht wurde, aber das ist auch,
spekulieren ja was heißt Spekulation? Die genauen Daten haben wir nicht. Man könnte aber auch mal rechnen vier Komma zwei Millionen Verbindungsdaten. Berlin hat drei Komma sechs Millionen Einwohner,
statistisch ist mindestens jeder einmal drin.
Hm. Ja gut, jetzt kommen wir wieder zu dieser klassischen Frage, ne? Stört einen das? Hat man denn was zu verbergen.
Wie heißt der? Gunnar.
Nicht.
Aber mich stört das. Also mit wem ich telefoniere und wo ich dabei bin,
Erstmal niemand was an, solange ich kein äh konkreter Verdächtiger in einer konkreten Straftat bin.
Ja, das Problem ist ja jetzt gar nicht mal, dass dass man daraufhin abgeklopft wird, ob man denn nun äh ein Auto angezündet hat, sondern das ist das, diese Daten natürlich genauso auch auf andere Dinge jetzt abgeklopft werden könnten.
Und sie ja außer der Kontrolle sind. Gab's denn eine Information darüber, ob diese Daten bereits gelöscht wurden?
Es wurden schon Daten gelöscht. Ähm mehrere Millionen,
Es sind aber bei weitem nicht alle Daten gelöscht und mindestens eine, ich glaube, mindestens eins Komma sieben Millionen dieser Daten sind noch nicht gelöscht. Das wurde auch vom Bundesdatenschutz,
vom Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten Doktor Dicks sehr kritisiert
dass im Gesetz überhaupt nicht steht, wie lange die Polizei die ähm also wann die Polizei diese Daten löschen muss, denn theoretisch
dürfen die, die sie so lange behalten wie die Ermittlungen andauern und bei den vielen Autobrandstiftungen, wo man noch nie irgendjemand,
geschweige denn ein äh Ermittlungs,
Abschluss aller Taten hatte, könnte das theoretisch lange aufbewahrt bleiben und ich glaube von denen, die seit dem Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgericht,
vor gut zwei Jahren abgefragt wurden. Es ist noch keine einzige eine einzige Datensatz wieder gelöscht,
Datensätze wurden teilweise, wenn das Verfahren an andere Behörden wie Bundeskriminalamt oder Bundesanwaltschaft abgegeben wurden, auch diesen anderen Behörden gegeben,
Was die Polizei tatsächlich noch mit äh mit diesen Daten macht, mit welchen anderen Datenbanken sie das eventuell korreliert äh statt nur untereinander, sondern irgendwie,
Linksextremismus, politisch motivierte Straßengewalt oder was es da alles für Dateien gibt. Das hat sie äh so nicht gesagt leider.
Hm. Was war so dein Eindruck? Du hast ja bei dem, bei den Innenausschusssitzungen, äh was war nochmal gleich der andere Ausschuss, der sich damit beschäftigt hat?
IT und Datenschutz.
Mhm. Da warst du auch.
Da war ich leider nur kurz und habe nur die letzten zehn Minuten mitbekommen.
Was war so dein Eindruck von diesen beiden Ausschüssen so generell?
Also der wichtigste war der Innenausschuss, wo tatsächlich auch die Verantwortlichen waren und nicht nur die Datenschützer. Ähm und ich habe so, da wurde ich auch teilweise kritisiert, äh ein recht,
Ähm pessimistisches Fazit, äh gestern auf Netzpolitik nochmal nachgeschoben.
Ich glaube, dass das jetzt war, dass das in der Berliner Landespolitik erstmal keine Folgen hat, denn die SPD und die Union,
Die beiden Regierungsparteien die finden das alles völlig knorke, wenn die Daten da sind, müssen die auch genutzt werden. Autobrandstiftung ist eine schwere Straftat und die Polizei hat nur nach Recht und Gesetz gehandelt. Und was Recht ist, kann erstmal nicht falsch sein,
Es gab dann Kritik von einzelnen Oppositionsparteien, quasi also von allen eigenen Piraten Grüne und Linke. Aber die haben auch nicht wirklich was zu sagen. Zumal das ist ja auch ein Bundesgesetz,
Die Strafprozessordnung und dann kann da kann das Land Berlin erstmal so nicht ran. Ja,
Was eventuell noch was bringen könnte, abgesehen von irgendwelchen Forderungen nach Rücktritt oder sowas, wäre eine äh Westigation des Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten,
der sich auch sehr erstaunt darüber gezeigt hat, was für ein Ausmaß das annimmt, wie viele Millionen von Daten das sind, wie lange die gespeichert werden und vor allem, dass kein einziger der betroffenen Personen jemals darüber informiert wurde, obwohl seine Rechtsauffassung ist, dass das unbedingt geschehen muss,
Wenn das nicht passiert, muss das im Einzelfall begründet werden. Er will da jetzt ähm recherchieren, nachprüfen ob das alles korrekt
nicht nur nach Strafprozessordnung, sondern auch nach Bundes- und Landesdatenschutzgesetzen abgelaufen ist. Und vielleicht kommt es
in dem Zuge zu einer Einschränkung dieser Maßnahme, aber das kam mir gestern nicht so, als ob es einen breiten Konsens vor allem der äh Regierungsparteien gab, dass man das jetzt irgendwie ändern müsste.
Also die Effizienz der Maßnahme wird man sicherlich auch nochmal beleuchten müssen, weil wenn ich tatsächlich,
also man würde ja erwarten, dass sich mit so einem Ansatz, okay, ich mache da eine eine Ortsüberwachung und kriege, schaue mir von mir aus mehrere Tatorte an, dass ich relativ schnell und auf ein sehr kleinen Personenkreis
äh stoße, der sich immer in diesen Bereichen aufhält, aber es.
Die da wohnen, ne? Genau.
Genau, die, ja, gut, aber die die wohnen ja immer nur an einem Ort und die Autos werden ja dann irgendwo anders angezündet. Ähm neunhundertsechzig,
Person, damit's zu identifizieren. Also ist ja auch ein lässt ja auch groben großen Zweifel an dieser Maßnahme überhaupt. Also finde ich eigentlich relativ überraschend, dass die so viele so einen großen Täterkreis,
offensichtlich irgendwie Verdächtigen oder Leute haben, die da in Frage kommen. Plus, sie haben ja ihre ähm ohnehin schon ihre
Datenbanken, wo sie gefährliche linksradikale irgendwie drin speichern, wie wir ja den Artikel
verlinken wir einfach mal nur die Geschichte von Anti-Schocke, die da irgendwie mal zu Unrecht irgendwo verhaftet wurde und Jahre später beim beim Bundespräsidenten sich also,
Nicht beim Bundespräsidenten selber, aber äh bei einem Empfang des Bundespräsidenten.
Von der Polizei zur Seite genommen wurde und durchsucht wurde, ja. Mhm.
Weil sie,
eingestelltes Verfahren wegen irgendwelcher Krawalle hatte, wo sie absolut unschuldig ist, wer sie kennt, kann sich das auch sehr gut vorstellen, dass sie damit nichts zu tun hatte. Sie war irgendwie äh trotzdem Nacht, obwohl sie da freigesprochen wurde und alles äh alles von.
Bestätigt wurde, dass sie ja, dass das ja nicht gespeichert werden würde.
Ja, weil ist sie offensichtlich in irgendeiner Schattendatenbank, wo die Lichter angehen, wenn ihr Personalausweis kontrolliert wird. Und steht, Achtung, Linke, pass mal lieber auf. Ja und solche Datenbanken hast du ja auch noch, damit kannst du das auch alles abgleichen.
Eine kurze Nachfrage dieser.
Kann ich nochmal ganz kurz dazu gleich anschließen,
Dass es in der Tat ein bisschen widersprüchlich, die Polizeivizepräsidentin hat gestern gesagt, äh wir haben geguckt, welche Mobilfunkengeräte an vier oder fünf,
Tatorten zur Tatzeit auftauchen, haben uns wollten uns die dann genauer angucken, haben da aber niemand wirklich gefunden.
Also keine äh keine der Mobilfunkgeräte, die irgendwie an vier oder fünf,
Tatorten. Ich glaube der selben Serie äh aufgetaucht wären. Ähm gleichzeitig haben die aber eben die fast eintausend äh sogenannten Standarten eben Name Adresse der Anschlussinhaber eingeholt, was,
so erstmal nicht ganz zusammenpasst.
Haben die denn gesagt, wie also wenn diese neunhundertsechzig müssen ja nur durch irgendetwas aufgefallen sein. Was war das, wodurch die aufgefallen sind? War das die das haben sie aber nicht gesagt.
Das hätte ich auch gerne mal gewusst, das habe ich dir auch gefragt, das haben sie so nicht gesagt. Meine These ist ja die gleichen, dass eben wie schon angesprochen mit anderen Datenbanken ab.
Das heißt, das ist gar nicht mal so wahr, dass die an zwei Orten vielleicht mindestens mal aufgetaucht sind.
Naja, das kann ich nicht sagen. Das kann gut sein, dass das mindestens zwei gewesen sein oder eben, dass das Mobiltelefon ohnehin schon einem einschlägigen Verdächtigen gehört.
Wäre, sagen wir mal, das wäre aber doch mal ein sehr interessanter Punkt, wo man nachhaken könnte.
Muss man Polizei und Staatsanwaltschaft fragen, hätte ich auch gern mal gewusst.
Wäre vielleicht was für unsere Oppositionsparteien an der Stelle, um dann nochmal nachzuhaken äh in irgendeiner kleinen Anfrage. Was mich jetzt, was mir jetzt auch noch kurz äh auffiel,
Diese Person, die gefunden wurde, die der diese hundert Brandstiftungen nachgesagt werden. Also mir ist diese Zahl neu, aber du meinst, das stimmt. Äh.
Ist die denn die ist ja auch in Flagranti aufgegriffen worden, oder?
Und der Fall ist ein Stück zurück und ich weiß es nicht ganz genau, ich glaube mich zu erinnern, dass ähm BVG, Kameravideos,
geführt haben, dass diese Person äh an den jeweiligen Tatorten aufgetaucht ist und da jeweils mit dem Bus hingefahren ist und im Bus eine Kamera.
Ja, den hatten die irgendwie.
Im Nachhinein haben sie jetzt gesagt, sie haben dann überprüft, ob sein Handy auch in der Nähe der äh Tatorte war mit dieser Funkzellenauswertung und haben das wohl damit bestätigt,
Das war aber nicht der Grund, wie sie den äh überhaupt gefunden haben. Sie hatten sein.
Handy und eigentlich hätten sie ihn dann auch schon rausfinden können.
Ja das weiß ich nicht genau, irgendwie haben die gemeint bei vier dieser hundert Taten haben sie dann in den Verbindungs-, in den Funkzellendaten,
dass dein Handy da aufgetaucht ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie da jetzt über alle komplett gerastet haben,
Zumindest hat die funktionellen Auswertungen nicht zu seiner Ermittlung und Ergreifung geführt, sondern eher zur Bestätigung.
Mhm. Na ja, kann man ja auch schon als Erfolg verbuchen.
Ja, wenn hätte man uns das damals gesagt, als man die Vorratsdatenspeicherung eingeführt hat? Das man genau das, damit machen will, dann hätte das, glaube ich, keine politischen Mehrheiten, zumindest dafür gegeben. Ich glaube ja auch,
Informationspflicht finde ich sehr interessant, dass die Leute darüber informiert werden müssen, wenn Daten von ihnen angefallen werden. Ähm,
Zumindest der Landesdatenschutzbeauftragte sagt klipp und klar, zumindest diese neunhundertsechzig Leute, deren Namen und Adressenmann eingeholt hat,
muss man jetzt benachrichtigen, man muss den Brief schreiben, hallo, wir haben deine Daten da und dafür, für so und so lange, ähm, erhalten, damit abgeglichen und dann und dann wieder gelöscht,
und eigentlich gibt es auch keinen Grund,
warum man die übrigen Handydaten nicht auch noch einschreiben sollte. Man äh die Polizei sagt, ja man müsste erstmal den Namen rauskriegen, um den Brief zu schreiben. Aber man hat ja die Rufnummer. Man kann ihn ja einfach anrufen oder eine SMS schreiben,
steht im Gesetz nirgendwo auf welchem Wege das zu erfolgen hat. Und ich glaube, wenn man.
Dieser Abhörspam. Andauernd SMS.
Und ich glaube, wenn man das tatsächlich bei allen Leuten, die davon betroffen sind, machen würde, dann hätte man erst recht keine politische Mehrheit für eine Vorratszeitenspeicherung mehr,
Weil dann den Leuten das wirklich mal klar ist, was das eigentlich bedeutet und dass das eben nicht nur um den einzelnen Terroristen geht, sondern tatsächlich betroffen sind.
Mitteilung, SMS.
Oder Anruf. Es wäre auch bestimmt, wenn's um Polizeihauptkommissar anruft und sagt, ja, Entschuldigung.
Wäre relativ schnell Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgegner.
Na ja, also eine SMS mit einer beliebigen Absendeadresse zu verschicken, ist technisch kein großes Problem. Könnte man ja mal alle.
Aber einen Brief auch nicht. Was? Einen Brief? Auch nicht.
Was? Ja, auch einen Brief nicht, wobei so große Briefmengen na ja, gut, wir wollen jetzt zunächst anstiften, aber.
Wer wer vielleicht gar nicht so.
Potenzial.
Äh Brief würde diese ganze Sache nämlich kostspielig machen. Wenn man also wirklich gesetzlich verankern würde, musst du einen Brief schicken, dann würde, müsste die Polizei sich nämlich zweimal überlegen, ob sie diese Daten anfordert, die sie zwar einerseits kostenlos
sicherlich bekommt und ohne großen Aufwand, das kostet ja nicht viel, aber wenn sie dann nachher jedem, der da drin ist, äh einen Brief schreiben müssen mit einer persönlichen äh Entschuldigung, dann werden sie sich überlegen, wie viele Zellen sie abfragen.
Na gut, ich meine bei neunhundertsechzig ist das äh in der Tat ja noch.
In der Nähe die neue Moment, ich würde ja dann schon sagen, alle Leute, die die irgendwie in dieser Zelle waren und das sind ja sehr viel mehr.
Aber wenn sie, ja gut, aber wenn sie.
Das wären jetzt vier Komma zwei Millionen Daten, nehmen wir.
Na gut, aber aber die haben ja bei diesem, also weiß ich nicht ganz genau, äh neunhunderttausend Personen werden das, wenn man mal diesen Dresden-Faktor da äh mit einrechnen ungefähr.
Ist eine halbe Million Euro Porto.
Ja gut, aber von denen wurden ja nicht wirklich die persönlichen Daten.
Ach so, ja, okay.
Falls, sondern es war ja an der Stelle quasi nur Rohdaten, die wenn nicht anonym dann zumindest in dem Zusammenhang äh in der Untersuchung erstmal.
Ich ziehe den Vorschlag zurück. Ich ziehe den Vorschlag zurück.
Wäre in der Tat noch mein Unverhältnismäßiger Eingriff überhaupt, dass deren Namen und Adressen zu ermitteln. Aber man hat ja eine Kontaktmöglichkeit.
Ja, also ich meine, bei neunhundertsechzig wär's durchaus noch zu leisten gewesen, also selbst das Argument, dass man das ja nicht leisten könne, würde an der Stelle nicht greifen, ne.
Ja, die leisten's ja immerhin sich auch diese Daten anzuschauen, ja, dann können sie.
Genau.
Die Polizei hat gestern noch ein schönes ähm Zitat gebracht, denen war das Interesse an einer Benachrichtigung nicht ersichtlich. Hat Frau Polizeivizepräsidentin Coppers gestern gesagt.
Ach so.
Die Leute, die die keine Ahnung hatten, haben ja überhaupt nicht gesagt, dass sie äh,
Naja, das ist das ist das ist interessant. Interessante Argumentation,
Ja, haben wir noch einen wichtigen Aspekt dieser Geschichte ausgelassen, sonst würde ich vorschlagen, dass wir uns auch nochmal der restlichen Themenwelt etwas widmen. Wir haben jetzt ganz bewusst
diesem Thema, ob der äh Dimension und Aktualität hier etwas mehr Raum eingeräumt, aber man ist ja auch nicht übertreiben. Linus?
Ja, ich denke, gehen wir, gehen wir weiter. Äh dieses Thema lässt sich ja auf jeden Fall weiterverfolgen bei Netzpolitik ORG Slash Offer slash André oder was, wie ist deine.
Bist nicht der Einzige, der darüber schreibt jetzt, oder?
Netzpolitik org.
Ja, dann äh gab's ja noch äh eine ganz wilde Aktivität äh Lokbuchnetzpolitik berichtete. Der äh Sopa äh Blackout Day
im Kampf gegen Sopa und Pieper die beiden Gesetzesvorschläge im äh amerikanischen äh Kongress und äh der andere war im Senat richtig
dich.
Abgeordnetenhaus.
Kongress ist beides, oder? Nee, Mist.
Super, super Basisbildung liegt hier vor. Ihr seid an der richtigen Adresse, um euch umfangreich
informieren zu lassen. Und ähm wie auch immer äh
Der Widerstand war dann doch signifikant, vor allem meine Wahrnehmung getrieben durch diese Wikipedia-Aktion, weil das war nun wirklich etwas mit dem, die Webseite, mit der wirklich jeder was anfangen kann, abgesehen von Facebook, Facebook war meines Wissens
Schwarz, gab's da zumindest irgendwelche.
Max Zuckerberg hat einen Blogpost geschrieben, glaube ich.
Oh.
Ja. Oder ein schreibt er, schreibt er eigentlich noch Blogpost oder schreibt er in seine Pinnwand? Ich weiß es nicht. Äh ja.
Auf jeden Fall, dass ich nicht grade jetzt den Pokal findest, Aktivist des Jahres abgeholt. Wie auch immer, wir wollen das gar nicht weiter bewerten, trotz alledem Wikipedia, denke ich mal, das ist halt auch diesen großen Vorteil, da ist einem,
jedem einfach auch so der der, der, der Nutzen klar. Und dadurch, dass die Wikipedia-Gemeinde es geschafft hat, sich da auch wirklich mal darauf zu einigen, diesen Protest sich anzuschließen,
Schon mal ein ein Wert in sich darstellt, wie ich finde. Ähm war dann das Medienecho auf diese Aktion doch erheblich.
Und führte auch dazu, dass äh die geplante Abstimmung so nicht stattfand.
Ähm wobei das, glaube ich, im Falle von Sopa schon vorher äh sich irgendwie angekündigt hatte, dass sie das verschieben wollen würden.
Ja, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt waren auch die Proteste bereits angekündigt. Also es war absehbar und,
Noch ein interessanter Punkt, also allein die Ankündigung von Wikipedia äh sich schwarz zu schalten, ja? Also es war gar nicht mal so sehr die Reaktion der Öffentlichkeit darauf,
erforderlich, sondern schon die Absehbarkeit der Reaktionen darauf dürfte schon Dinge in Bewegung gebracht haben.
Ja, ich glaube, das war aber auch die Aktivität von vielen, vielen Verbänden und klassischer Kampagnen und Lobbyarbeit äh in Amerika und vor allem Washington, DC, von Freunden wie EFF, Access Now und so weiter und so fort, die
beigetragen hat, nicht nur der Wikipedia Blackout, zumindest um die Anhörung im Vorhinein schon zu verschieben.
Ja, ich fand das jetzt auch gar nicht äh überhöhen oder die die Arbeit der anderen Gruppen da zurückstellen. Es war nur wie gesagt, meine meine Wahrnehmung, dass das einfach ein erheblicher Faktor war, um diese diese Aktivität zu verstärken in der Öffentlichkeit, ne.
Also was was,
ja eine sehr beliebte Reaktion war, das war sehr schön auf Twitter zu beobachten, waren dann Leute, die sich über die Kommunistenschweine von Wikipedia beschwert haben
die jetzt die Seite abgeschaltet haben, wo sie doch äh morgen irgendwie ihren ihren Referat halten müssten oder ihr ihre Hausarbeit abgeben. Da gab's also einen riesigen
Shitstorm, der sehr amüsant war, den man sich dann noch durchlesen konnte auf Twitter, weil da nicht wirklich äh alle Verständnis für gezeigt haben für diese Maßnahme.
Das hat, glaube ich, Einfluss gehabt, dass das tatsächlich nicht nur eine Vorschaltseite war
sondern man auch äh und nicht ohne Weiteres die Inhalte der Wikipedia noch lesen konnte. Ich meine, wenn man ein hatte, war das immer noch der, weil das irgendwie ein ja, was gelöst
war oder so, aber für die Masse der Internetnutzer war die Wikipedia nicht als ihr eigentlichen Zweck dienende Wissensarmende zu gebrauchen,
das hat schon ganz schön Eindruck gemacht.
Hm.
Stellt sich die Frage, wie es da jetzt politisch weitergeht? Äh sicherlich wird der äh eigentliche Drive da äh eine Gesetzesinitiative
noch weiter zu entwickeln, noch nicht komplett verloren sein, aber es scheint zumindest schon mal in einigen Gruppen
der amerikanischen politischen Klasse angekommen zu sein, dass es jetzt so einfach nicht mehr ist.
Ja, also,
das auf jeden Fall. Ähm was ja dann noch weiter, was gerade in Deutschland hier in unserem Bereich dann oder in Europa ganz gut geklappt hat, also,
Als die Aktion irgendwie geplant wurde, ähm,
habe ich da noch nicht so dran geglaubt, aber es wurde ja in Deutschland das sehr stark genutzt, um auf die Bedrohung durch Acta aufmerksam zu machen, wo ja,
wieder ähnliche Möglichkeiten diskutiert werden, die eben auch bei Super und Pieper äh nicht akzeptabel sind,
Und da gab's, glaube ich, eine sehr große Aufmerksamkeit, die das Augenmerk darauf gerichtet hat bei uns, in Europa.
Woran machst du das fest, dass sie Aufmerksamkeit da war?
Das mache ich daran fest, dass irgendwie der Blogpost von digitaler Gesellschaft einundsechzig Track Backs hat und irgendwie wo auch in welchem Blog auch immer du liest oder in welchem Artikel auch immer du dazu liest, Akta dann auch Erwähnung findet, was ich erstmal ganz,
ganz positiv finde, dass das dass eben nicht nur in überall berichtet wurde, ja die USA wollen irgendwie ein komisches Gesetz machen,
sondern dass hier tatsächlich dann eine vernünftige inhaltliche Berichterstattung stattfand, wo eben gesagt wird und das ist nicht irgendwie nur wieder bei den anderen, sondern das interessiert uns aus diesen und jenen Gründen ähm und das droht uns auch,
erstmal einen sehr positiven Effekt.
Schon mehrfach angekündigt, wollten wir uns hier auch nochmal ein bisschen genauer anschauen, werden wir heute nicht machen, aber ich setze es nochmal auf die Gedankenliste.
Vielleicht eine Anmerkung noch, dass wann ähm war das jetzt mit dem polnischen Blackout, dass tatsächlich,
Polen ist irgendwie gestern, vorgestern schon Dedos gegen polnische Regierungszeiten gab,
unter dem Banner äh Protest gegen Akta, weil das da demnächst tatsächlich auf nationaler Ebene entschieden werden soll. Und es gab oder gibt sogar schon einen Black
von polnischen Text eben im Zuge dieser Proteste, um auch Acta auf polnisch nationaler Ebene zu thematisieren.
Ein Termin, an dem das stattfinden soll oder es gab schon einen oder das ist immer noch aktiv. Äh.
Von beim AK Vorrat möchte der polnische Außenminister oder ein Vertreter dieses Abkommens am sechsundzwanzigsten Januar unterzeichnen. Wir wissen ja, es ist ein
ein ein Abkommen, wo eben alle möglichen Vertragsparteien zu unterschreiben haben und das in Europa muss jetzt einmal von der von dem von Europa selber,
werden und dann nochmal von jedem Mitgliedsstaat und da Polen möchte das also jetzt am sechsundzwanzigsten ersten unterzeichnen und
war dann der polnische Blackout Day war dann gestern am dreiundzwanzigsten ersten.
Da wurde dazu aufgerufen, ja.
Und ähm vierundzwanzigsten ersten steht im also heute im Europaparlament ein Austausch von Argumenten an der Tagesordnung. Da bin ich mal sehr gespannt.
Genau, das ist der Verlauf da.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall habe ich so das den Eindruck, das wird nicht der letzte Blackout Day gewesen sein, den wir hier sehen, so das äh hat jetzt mal ganz gut funktioniert und könnte schon so zu so einem Standard äh Reaktion werden, ne. Nur die Frage wäre dann da mitmacht.
Gibt's ja auch schon ewig, aber das war halt jetzt echt dick.
Ja, bisher waren's halt immer nur so die die üblichen Verdächtigen, die sich selber äh eingetüncht haben oder mit äh schwarzem Trauerflor bedeckt haben, das hat natürlich so äh wenige interessiert.
Selbst Google hat sich einen schwarzen Balken vorgemacht, also es wir verlinken mal noch so ein paar Galerieseiten für Leute, die in der Zeit äh.
Mhm. Die romantisch noch schwelgen wollen in der Demonstrationswelle.
Damals ein Tag ohne Internet.
Ja, wobei die meisten vielleicht auch gesagt haben, wieso Facebook geht da noch.
Ja, das äh genau das habe ich ja auch gedacht, also das Facebook Frage ist halt, ob man Facebook bei sowas dabei haben will und ähm trotzdem sei nochmal nachgeschoben, dass ja auch,
bei uns in den Kommentaren zu zu der letzten Folge von einem äh Leser angemerkt wurde,
Man muss sich jetzt so, wenn Wikipedia und so das für die gute Sache machen, ist das schön und gut. Was ist, wenn demnächst irgendwelche sollten,
irgendwie mal eine Datenschutzreform anstehen und Facebook ist dagegen und dann schalten die äh da ihr Facebook ab oder die sind mal mit der Steuergesetzgebung nicht zufrieden,
Äh ist natürlich ein Mittel, was ähm hoffentlich nur sehr selten Einsatz finden muss und dann auch nur mit äh entsprechenden Themenbezug.
Ja, der Kommentar war von mir und ich halte das tatsächlich für noch äh offen,
Das ist auch eine Macht, die man damit hat, eben zu sagen, hier ein Tag Internet aus, Facebook aus, ruf mal deinen Abgeordneten an,
Bisher waren die auf der guten Seite und ich glaube, ohne Rückhalt in der Netzcommunity kann man das auch schwer machen. Ähm tatsächlich hat die kleine Netzcommunity aber viel weniger Impact, als wenn ganz Facebook das macht.
Mhm. Das stimmt.
Da stellen sich ganz neue Fragen von Macht und Herrschaft im Internet.
Ja, neue Fragen,
und auch alte Fragen stellt auch das Thema äh wie gehen wir denn mit den Nazis äh so um? Auch das hatten wir ja jetzt hier äh in der letzten Sendung, glaube ich, sogar schon noch,
äh gehabt äh durch diese ganzen Nazi äh Hacks, Nazi Leaks et cetera. Jetzt gibt's einen neuen schönen Vorschlag unseres äh Innenministers,
scheint auch so 'n so 'n Standard zu sein. Oh, wir haben da ein Problem, dann brauchen wir mal eine Zentraldatei, jetzt sollen halt die Nazis dran glauben,
warum das jetzt erst kommt. Bisher ging's halt immer gegen die Linken, aber offensichtlich hat äh die Tatsache, äh dass sich die öffentlichen Stellen bei dieser ganzen Verfolgung dieser Chemnitzer,
äh Terrorbande so blamiert hat, äh bisschen Auswirkungen gezeigt.
Zwickau, Jena, wahlweise.
Entschuldigung. Habe ich Chemnitz gesagt? Ich habe Chemnitz gesagt, Entschuldigung, Chemnitz, war nicht so gemeint.
Genau, da hat der Friedrich schon im November letzten Jahres dann gesagt, er möchte also eine zentrale zentrales Neonazi-Register haben. Sowas haben wir, glaube ich, auch über Islamisten.
Und äh wie ja wir grade schon erwähnt haben, auch in Schattenform, die nicht wirklich äh,
dokumentiert es unbedingt und wahrscheinlich auch nicht wirklich legal eben von Linken, Limo, Limo Liste heißt die, glaube ich, ne?
Smotivierte potenzielle Gewalttäter oder sowas oder potenzielle Straftäter.
Genau. Die Liste von potenziellen Straftätern ist natürlich sehr gut. Und äh das hat dann unser Freund äh Friedrich im November vorgeschlagen und letzte Woche Mittwoch.
Innenminister.
Ja äh letzte Woche Mittwoch hat dann das Kabinett diesem Gesetzesentwurf beschlossen, das heißt, er soll jetzt eingebracht werden.
Und da gab's dann auch sofort von der, also mein, mein persönliches, mein persönliches Highlight im Internet ist ja der Rainer Wendt,
von der Polizeigewerkschaft. Das ist so, das ist so ein Leuchtturm, Leuchtturm der Aufklärung. Die Pressemitteilung, die von.
Ist denn seine Funktion?
Vorsitzender der Deutschen Polizeigewerkschaft,
Und der hat natürlich zu dieser äh Nazidatei gesagt, das wäre also äh ein ein unzureichender Schritt in die richtige Richtung, weil da sollen ja nur die Nazis rein,
besser wäre, wenn man da auch noch ihre Freunde, Bekannten und Familien drin hätte, damit man die Daten vernünftig auswerten kann und er wollte bei dieser Gelegenheit auch nicht müde werden, zu betonen, dass man wieder eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung braucht
um ähm Nazi-Angriffe zu verhindern.
Kann man, dem kann man wenig hinzufügen. Rainer Wendt, Spitzentyp.
Um Nazi-Angriffe zu verhindern, weil wie man ja in Dresden gesehen hat, es nicht ausreicht, wenn die Polizei direkt neben dem Nazi-Angriff steht mit äh Einsatzwagen, ja, da kann man ja dann nichts tun.
Hilft nur noch Funzeleinsatz.
Genau.
Der Typ ist, der hat's echt drauf,
also mein absolutes Highlight von ihm war damals als es um Google ging, hatte er dann verlautbaren lassen, dass sie noch prüfen, ob man mit Google Street You auf Streife gehen kann. Und,
Also ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich da so vorstellen, wie sie sich so durch Google's Review klicken und gucken, ob überall alles in Ordnung ist.
Graben bestimmt noch die drei die graben bestimmt noch die drei D Kameras irgendwie aus den neunziger Jahren irgendwie raus mit Cyberhandschuhe und so weiter.
Der Typ ist super.
Also ich bin ja gespannt, wie lange es dauert, bis diese Neonazi-Zentraldatei denn auch für äh die sogenannten Linksextremisten, was ja in,
unseren neuen äh Familienministerin gern gleichgesetzt wird, ähm eingesetzt wird und äh ich sehe das,
generell kritisch so eine neue Datei in dieser Form zu machen,
Wenn ich jetzt hier schon mal zu Gast bin, kann ich vielleicht mal Werbung machen für zwei andere Podcasts bei und zwar war das antifaschistische Pressearchiv und Bildungszentrum,
die sehr, sehr viel Einblick in die Neonazi-Szene und antifaschistische Arbeit und Recherche haben zu Gast bei im Medienradio glaube ich,
und auf dem Radio der Gruppe Fels Aranka dot org und die haben dort gesprochen aus einer professionellen Ebene von Leuten, die sich seit zwanzig Jahren,
ähm professionell mit antifaschistischer Recherche beschäftigen, wie sinnlos diese Dateien sind, denn es ist ja nicht so, dass diese.
Die untergetochten oder anderen äh hochkarätigen äh bereiten Neonazis nicht bekannt wären,
es ist auch nicht so, dass man irgendwie sich irgendwie rausreden könnte, ja man hat das jetzt anderen Behörde X nicht mitgeteilt oder so, die die Namen sind ja,
für jeden, der sich interessiert, tatsächlich erfahrbar. Insofern ist, halt ich die Neonati zentral tatsächlich auch für ein bisschen Augenwischerei und ähm.
Um zu zeigen, man tut ja jetzt was, aber das Problem ist viel grundsätzlicher, aber das müssen wir jetzt, glaube ich, nicht im Lokbuchnetzpolitik äh noch erörtern, die ganze Verstrickung der Behörden und so weiter. Ich empfehle diese beiden Podcasts mit.
Medienradio, Ausgabe vierundfünfzig vom dritten Januar zwanzig zwölf, Nazis und die Medien und äh da habe ich jetzt nicht ganz mit.
Es war Aranka dot org, ähm kleiner Podcast, der Gruppe Fels aus Berlin unter Folge vier, glaube ich, auch zu Rechtsterrorismus.
Aranka, wie schaffst du das?
ARNCA.
Ah, okay. Aranka, alles klar. Folge vier. Okay.
Folge vier genau die Gruppe für eine linke Strömung. Die war noch letztens im Metrolaut Podcast zu Gast.
Im Metrolauten. Das sind die ersten äh das ist sind die echten Spezialexperten, wenn's um ähm,
Ja, nicht nur Neonazi Dateien, aber um ähm Recherche der radikalen Rechten in Deutschland geht und die machen in meinen Augen oft eine bessere Arbeit als die diversen Behörden.
Mhm. Ja, super Tipp. Alle Links in den Shownotes. Linus, du bist schon dran, ne? Bist du ganz fleißiger.
Ja ja, ich bin fleißig am.
Das wird die die Linkreichste Sendung äh überhaupt werden.
Sonntag schon angefangen, links einzupflegen.
Das ist eine ganz tolle Idee. So, kommen wir zu unserem.
Ganz kurz noch äh genau, es gibt noch einen Artikel, wo wir gerade schon Metro Nord erwähnt haben, von äh John F Nebels dem Thema, den verlinke ich auch, der also dann noch mal darüber
weiter ausführt, warum man auch bei Neonazis keine solche Datei haben möchte, weil es auch da ein Angriff gegen die Bürgerrechte ist.
Okay. So, dann kommen wir zum vierten und.
I like, mega Upload.
Das Liedchen spielen wir jetzt nicht, aber äh nicht nur das hat äh eine Menge Welle gemacht im äh äh im Netz. Ähm was ist passiert? Mega Upload, einer dieser.
Sharehoster.
Sharehorster nennt man das, ja, also diese Webseiten, man kennt das, man kriegt da so einen Link mit hier. Tolle Datei, lad's dir runter, dann klickt man da drauf und dann kriegt man erstmal so ein bisschen äh den Countdown vor die Nase. Hier äh kannst ja mal äh,
Drei Minuten warten, dann darfst du es dir auch langsam runterladen, aber du könntest uns ja auch Geld geben, dann geht's nicht nur sofort, sondern auch schnell. Und äh mega Upload hat sich da so in den letzten Jahren zu,
Vielleicht dem größten und bekanntesten äh dieser Hoster äh entwickelt, was darüber so alles getretet wurde, weiß man nicht, aber ähm viel,
wurde da gemutmaßt, dass äh auch sagen wir mal äh Dateien mit Kopireiproblematiken äh in Bereich Software und äh Filme et cetera dabei gewesen sein dürften,
Nun wurde dieser Laden hochgenommen und äh die Leute, die dort,
in Neuseeland von ähm der neuseeländischen Polizei äh festgenommen wurden, waren zumindest zum Teil keine Unbekannten, natürlich vor allem der Chef von dem Ganzen. Kim Schmitz,
kein Unbekanntes Gesicht,
Insbesondere in der deutschen Szene, denn er ist ja Deutscher und ist ja auch schon früher durch die diverse äh Aktivitäten aufgefallen, auch Illegalen.
Genau, also vielleicht mal ganz kurz noch zu diesem Geschäftsmodell eines äh Sharehosters. Sie sagen, du kannst bei uns eine Datei hochladen
und andere können die dann runterladen. Wenn du irgendwie einen nicht bezahlten Account hast, dann haben wir eine gewisse Vorlaufzeit, wenn die Datei irgendwie
fünfundvierzig Tage nicht runtergeladen wird, dann löschen wir sie wieder, dann wird der Link irgendwie ungültig. Ähm gleichzeitig
ist das insofern in Anführungszeichen anonym, als dass es kein Listing gibt. Da gibt's also beim mega Upload gab es dann keine Seite auf der stand, hier sind unsere ähm hundert äh Dateien, die wir da irgendwie haben,
Und ähm also dadurch, dass sie selber kein Listing anbieten, machen sie sich quasi nicht schuldig, diese Daten tatsächlich auch anzubieten, weil darauf gelingt wird dann wieder von anderen Stellen,
Und äh diese sind ja für ihre ähm sollen ja für ihre Links wiederum nicht haftbar sein, ja? Also das heißt, sie nutzen da so ein bisschen diese Linkhaftung,
oder diese momentan nicht existente Linkhaftung aus, gegen die wir ja auch alle uns anstrengen wollen.
Ähm dass das also nicht der Fall sein wird, dass man dafür haftet, wohin man einen Link setzt oder vor allem wo äh was für,
links man vielleicht irgendwo in die Kommentare seiner Webseite geschrieben bekommt,
betreiben, also so verschiedene ist da jetzt der Fall zu sein, ähnlich wie bei Kino TO, diese listigen Seiten aber direkt mit,
Das heißt, sie machen irgendwie mega Upload und gleichzeitig irgendwelche anderen Blogs äh oder oder Foren oder was auch immer, bei denen mega Upload-Links veröffentlicht werden zu.
Material, was in der, was in vielen Fällen dann offensichtlich äh das Copyright verletzt. Und damit auch schön, also das Geschäftsmodell dabei ist natürlich dieser ganze
Diese ganze Währung, die man angezeigt bekommt und gleichzeitig diese Premium-Accounts, die gewisse Preise kosten. Äh und damit,
irgendwie ordentlich Material geliefert wird, hatte mega Abläufe dann auch noch so ein Belohnungssystem für Uploader beliebter Dateien. Also früher war das irgendwie, die haben Geld bekommen,
ab fünfzigtausend haben die dann irgendwie pro tausend Downloads irgendwie einen gewissen Betrag bekommen und äh Extraprämien für Toplistenplatzierungen,
Und später haben sie es ersetzt durch so eine Art Punktesystem, wo du Gratis-Premium-Accounts ähm oder,
bekommen hast, je nachdem wie viele Downloads du mit deinem Kram erreichst. Das heißt, äh es gab also ein Anreizsystem für Menschen dort, Material hochzuladen, was wiederum
viele herunterladen. Mit diesem Geschäftsmodell, was eben hauptsächlich darauf hustet, dass da eben auch auf Urheberrecht nicht so viel,
Wert gelegt wird oder was natürlich gerade dann, wenn Urheberrecht verletzt wird, sehr gut funktioniert, weil nur dann lohnt es sich ja.
Diesen ähm dieses mega Upload tatsächlich zu nutzen, haben sie hundertachtzig Millionen registrierte Nutzer bekommen,
Im Schnitt fünfzig Millionen Besuche pro Tag ähm in dem Video mega Upload-Song, behaupten sie irgendwie, dass sie vier Prozent des Internets ausmachen. Irgendwo war auch noch die Rede davon, dass das die dreizehnt größte,
Seite der des Internets überhaupt wäre oder drei Cent häufigst besuchte Seite. Aber was man eben dazu sagen muss
Das wurde ja dann von unter anderem Andreas Popp von der Piratenpartei in einer wohlüberlegten Pressemitteilung als Angriff auf die
Meinungsfreiheit gewertet, wenn Nonne es hat, dann sofort die äh Justice dot gof Seite, also die äh den Webauftritt des äh Justizministeriums der USA
einige Zeit nicht erscheinen lassen durch eine Attacke.
Aber nicht unbedingt jetzt in direkter Reaktion auf die Pressemitteilung der Piratenpartei, sondern.
Nee.
Weil sie das einfach für richtig gehalten haben.
Genau. Ähm genau, weil sie, weil sie ja so verärgert waren, dass mega Upload jetzt nicht mehr da ist, was man zum Megaupload und Kino TO sagen muss, das sind eben nicht und die freundlichen,
Filesharing Freunde, ja? Das sind wirklich organisierte,
kriminelle Geschäftsmodelle. Ja, sie, also mit dem, die mit Raubkopien Handel betreiben. Und das äh da ist, denke ich, ein sehr,
erkennbarer Unterschied zu,
irgendwelchen Überlegungen, was Fair-Use angeht oder was äh was vielleicht das Modell von The Pirate Bay ist, wo wirklich geteilt wird. Also die Jungs haben mit mit
bundemäßig organisierte Urheberrechtsverletzungen, bandenmäßig organisierten Urgeberrechtsverletzungen, da ein,
ein Millionengeschäft gemacht. Und.
Im Prinzip ausnutzen ist halt nach wie vor die
ja unterdurchschnittlichere äh Präsenz der Copyright Halter äh im Netz mit eigenen Angeboten, ja, das ist halt immer wieder die alte Convenience äh äh Diskussion
und äh und versucht wird halt jetzt mit der Keule äh wieder mal das Ganze zu unterbinden, dass es dann sehr schnell auf andere Angebote ausweicht, ja, die dann einen anderen Namen, andere Personen oder vielleicht noch nicht mal andere Personen haben
Das äh lässt sich jetzt auch immer wieder beobachten. Äh Andy Pop hat ja für also von der Piratenpartei, der ja da als der.
Urheberrechtsexperte.
Urheberrechtsexperte gehandelt wird, äh er hat da eine ganze Menge ähm Saures einstecken müssen, glaube ich, für diese Pressemitteilung hat sich dann später in seinem eigenen Blog nochmal dazu geäußert und das auch seine Position verteidigt,
Ähm im Kern ist eine Aussage, mag ja alles sein, dass äh Tim Schmitz und Megaupload äh alles üble Verbrecher sind.
Aber das sollte uns an der Stelle gar nicht interessieren, sondern äh hier ging es ja auch sozusagen eher um diesen wie er meinte, Weltpolizei Anspruch USA
ähm den es zu verhindern äh gelte äh wie es denn sein könnte, dass eben die Gesetzeslage der USA äh über den ganzen Planeten hinweg von anderen Nationen
ähm,
durchgeführt werden und das dann eben auch vielleicht zu Auslieferungen führt, wobei ich glaube Auslieferungsantrag ist einer gestellt worden da in äh Neuseeland wissen wir nicht ähm
unserem Kenntnisstand nach, ist er zumindest ist die ganze Gruppe da noch in Neuseeland inhaftiert.
Was also was ich nur eigentlich feststellen wollte, ist, dass das wirklich nicht,
Also mit mit diesen Gruppen möchte man sich nicht unbedingt äh assoziieren, wenn man für äh Freiheit, Meinungsfreiheit und äh Bürgerrechte im Internet,
sprechen möchte. Da ist man vielleicht mit dieser Gruppe als Beispiel relativ schlecht beraten. Gibt ja was dann auch wieder hochquälte waren eben Artikel,
über den Kim Schmitz. Kimbel, kim dot com, wie auch immer er jetzt grade genannt wird. Ähm,
Schon irgendwie zu Mailbox Zeiten gecrackte Sachen äh verkauft hat und irgendwie dann urteilt wurde für Insiderhandel im Fall von dot co.
Vor allem interessant, sodass seine allererste Aktivität, die er überhaupt so entwickelt hat. Ja, nämlich eine Mailbox zu betreiben, in der halt Sachen zum Runterladen war, wo er dann eben auch gegen Geld äh quasi den Zugang äh den bevorzugten Zugang
normalerweise in der Mailbox-Szene mal reglementiert war, ja, du darfst nicht länger online sein, als weil die Leitungen wollen ja noch andere brauchen. Das hat er dann eben auch gegen Geld verkauft. Prinzip hat er sein altes Geschäftsmodell aus Kinderzeiten bei mega Upload wieder äh,
im großen Stil umgesetzt, ja.
Ja, also in Deutschland fiel das jetzt nicht auf besonders fruchtbaren Boden, auch der CCC im besonderen hatte ja mit ihm so alle Liebesmühe vor allem, weil er ja äh trotz seiner
ganzen äh illegalen Aktivitäten oder auch zumindest Zweifel ja, wie sagt man so schön, ähm.
Shady Activitys immer ja auch gerne äh mit dem,
der Bezeichnung Hacker äh gewedelt hat, dass er ja einer sei oder gewesen sei oder sein möchte, was auch immer
definiert sich, glaube ich, ohnehin sehr dadurch, was er gerne sein möchte. Und ähm im Club ist er da halt schon sehr früh, hat er da sehr früh auf Granit gebissen, wurde ja des Kongresses äh verwiesen et cetera,
Ja, also da gibt's nicht viele, die es geschafft haben, Hausverbot äh überhaupt zu erhalten beim CCC. Ähm da war er auf jeden Fall die Nummer eins. Ähm,
Wobei ihm solche Sachen wahrscheinlich auch eher gefallen haben, weil das ja alles Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt und davon schien er sich im Wesentlichen zu ernähren.
Und von Urheberrechtsverletzungen.
Deswegen, deswegen, deswegen ist,
sagen wir mal jetzt dieser dieser dieser Weg, den Andy Pop da gegangen äh äh ist, dass eben auch eine äh Ebene zu stellen mit ähm mit Pirat Bay oder zumindest Parallelen zu ziehen, sagen wir es mal so, ähm zumindest bisher äh in der öffentlichen Diskussion meiner
Meinung nach nicht so angekommen. Aber ist natürlich ein ein interessanter äh Punkt, den man auch diskutieren kann.
Also es ist in der Tat sehr aber bisher haben wir nur die Pressemitteilung vom FBI und die Sichtweise der Content-Industrie dazugehört.
Wir haben die Anklageschrift.
Ja, genau. Ähm,
Gegenseite quasi. Mega Upload stellt sich ja auf den Standpunkt. Man beachte den DMCA und wenn eine Tackdown Notes kommt, nimmt man das auch raus. Das wurde
in der Anklageschrift auch äh noch ein bisschen auseinander genommen, aber trotzdem sollten wir, glaube ich, abwarten
Auch wenn er ein sehr unangenehmer Zeitgenosse ist, wie das Verfahren, das jetzt kommt, äh ausgehen wird.
Also was was diese Takedown-Notises angeht, äh also es gibt den DMCA Digital Millennium Copyright Act und in dem,
Sind eben genau für solche Fälle ist irgendwie vorgesehen, dass sie möglichst schnelle Möglichkeiten bieten, solche Sachen,
dass wenn da irgendwie urheberrechtlich geschütztes Material ist, dass der rechte Inhaber sich möglichst schnell, dass es ein Verfahren dafür gibt, dass dieser Rechteinhaber sich da meldet und das verschwindet. Wer eventuell schon mal auf so einen Link geklickt hat, auf den sich,
völlig widererwartend hinter dem sich dann eine Copyright Verletzung äh befunden hat. Hat dann vielleicht auch schon mal gesehen, dass da stand äh dieses diese Datei wurde entfernt wegen einer Copyright Verletzung, was mega Upload aber offensichtlich
Hat in solchen Fällen ist, die haben nur die URL kaputt gemacht
Und die hatten quasi eine Depublikation laufen, das heißt, wenn ich eine Datei da hochgeladen habe, die sie schon mal hatten, dann haben sie mir,
entweder die gleiche URL oder eine neue gegeben, auf jeden Fall brauchte man da gar nicht mehr irgendwie großartig alles hochzuladen. Das heißt.
Nach dem Motto Hashtag erkannt und so.
Genau. Und dann haben sie halt.
Noch was im Cash und so.
Sie haben dann quasi, wenn also eine ähm Meldung kam, hallo, äh nehmt mal diese Datei da weg, dann haben sie halt diese URL blockiert und die gleiche Datei konnte unter,
anderen URLs durchaus noch erreichbar sein. Und weil's eben kein zentrales Listing beim Megaupload war, war dem eben nicht so. Äh sie haben so alles, was man irgendwie unter.
Unter verbuchen kann, haben sie irgendwie in dem Bereich.
Aber woher kommt diese Erkenntnis, dass sie das so getan hätten? Ist das einfach die Beobachtung.
Das ist eine das eine der Anschuldigungen der Anklageschrift, ja.
Und äh in dieser Ankergeschicht wird eben auch erwähnt, dass sie diesen diesen Umgang mit durchaus,
Sie hätten ja auch dann gleich den ganzen Hash sperren können und verhindern können, dass dieser Teil jemals wieder hochgeladen wird. Und das haben sie offensichtlich bei äh Kinderpornografie gemacht,
Also da war es quasi,
hatten sie einen effizienten Schutz gegen das äh Verwenden dieses für Kinderpornografisches Material, was dann wahrscheinlich technisch so umgesetzt war, dass sie hatten,
Und wenn dann irgendwie eine Datei hochkam, die ihn aus aus solchen Fällen bekannt war, dass sie die gar nicht erst angenommen oder veröffentlicht haben.
Also wie gesagt, ich finde das sehr fishi, aber ich glaube, da ist noch eine Menge Popcornpotential, denn Kim Schmitz hat sich erstmal irgendwie den Anwalt von Bill Clinton in der Lewinsky Affäre geholt,
irgendwie kann er jetzt wohl doch nicht mehr, aber ich glaube, der klotzt da auch eher, statt zu kleckern und ich glaube, da könnte auch vor Gericht noch ein bisschen was an Popcornpotential rauskommen.
Das auf jeden Fall, ein bisschen unglücklicher Nebeneffekt diese Sache ist eben auch, dass da jetzt Zahlen
stehen, ne? Und da gibt's jetzt quasi Nährboden mit Kino-Teo, mit mega. Das ist massenhaft äh Urheberrechtsverletzungen gibt, dass das äh ein Geschäftsmodell ist, dass das kriminell ist und so weiter
Da gibt's dann eben jetzt auch wieder Zahlen und Nährboden für, äh, das wirklich als
Kriminalität darzustellen und darauf also quasi wieder ein bisschen was für diese Argumentation Raubkopierer sind, Verbrecher und so weiter ähm da einen Nährboden zu haben.
Wurde auch vorgeworfen, damit Geld zu machen.
Nicht nur rein althroistisch, sondern dass die angeblich mit der Werbung Millionen verdienen würden. Deswegen ja auch die äh das Verfahren und die, ich glaube, Verurteilung dieses Jahr gab und nicht nur, weil sie einfach nur Urheberrecht verletzt haben.
Also das zieht sich durch wie ein roter Faden.
Ja
Das war's, oder? Unser Wochenrückblick. Auf jeden Fall äh eine Menge Themen, die auch so in der äh absehbaren nächsten Zeit eine Menge weitere Aktivität äh versprechen. Uns geht hier der Stoff nicht aus, habe ich den Eindruck.
Nee, überhaupt nicht, ne? Diese diese eine Woche Pause, die wir ja gemacht haben, wurde wieder, hat sich wieder schön gefüllt,
die Diskussion ja schon, ich würde ja es ich würde ja gerne noch den Megauploadsong einspielen, aber das geht ja leider nicht. Das war nämlich der vielleicht noch kurz zur Erwähnung, das war,
es ist erst wenige Wochen her, dass mega Upload irgendwie als
Meinungsfreiheit gegen die Content Mafia äh in den Blogs beziehungsweise äh einschlägigen Medien war, weil sie einen den mega Ablaufsong, in dem auch Richard Kimble sein Gesangstalent zur Verfügung stellt,
wo mehrere Stars dann irgendwie sagen, äh dass ihnen ein mega Upload gefällt. Und der wurde dann durch Universal gesperrt von YouTube.
Wodurch äh quasi auch als kleiner Nebeneffekt,
zweifellos klar war, dass Universal und diese großen äh Rechteinhaber Verwertung oder rechte Verwertungsfirmen quasi einen direkt Zugang auf YouTube haben,
Wo sie dieses unliebsame Material sich selber sperren, äh selber direkt von Hand entfernen können.
Das stimmt, das kam dadurch raus, ne? Durch.
Es gab ja lange lange die Überlegungen oder die Vermutung, dass das über äh Melodieerkennung oder irgendwelche gemacht wird,
und das ähm dass das YouTube quasi so einen automatischen Filter hat und dadurch ja dann vielleicht auch Sonnenalleder irgendwie verschwunden ist, weil man irgendwie rausgehört hat, der läuft im Hintergrund irgendwie ein Song für den und der und der das Recht hat oder so
und spätestens mit diesem mega Upload-Song, wo ja ganz offensichtlich die Rechte bei den Handwerk mega produziert,
der wurde halt dann durch Universe gesperrt. Und das war quasi ein ganz offensichtlicher Fall davon, dass Universal da diese,
ganz offensichtlich missbraucht hat, um irgendwie einen unliebigen Konkurrenten sei er auch kriminell, da irgendwie das YouTube-Video zu sperren.
Das war noch so und so das war quasi der, der Auftakt, das ist vielleicht drei Wochen her ungefähr oder vier, das war quasi dieser Auftakt zu ähm mega Upload als äh
Figur gegen die Content Mafia und hier Zensur und Papo. Vor dem Hintergrund.
Was ich noch, was ich noch gehört hatte und was vielleicht auch einer der Gründe war, warum sich da jetzt so viele bekannte äh Stars auch in diesem Video engagiert haben, ist, dass es durchaus auch ein, ein, ein, ein, äh, Verdienstmodell gab für.
Ja.
Bei mega Upload. Ich habe jetzt aber nicht mehr genau gespeichert, wie das aussah und inwiefern das wirklich Realität war oder nur ein Versprechen.
Das hatte der ähm Marcel Weiß. Bei.
Glaube ich, ne?
Bei Neunetz Dot com, der hatte da äh auf einen Artikel verwiesen. Ich glaube, von Techdirt äh,
Finde ich ihn gerade nicht. Also in dem quasi gesagt wird,
Musiker konnten mit mega Upload Geld verdienen und klar, du konntest ja,
wie gesagt, es stand ja nicht dabei, dass diese Datei, die du da hochlädst, unbedingt Urheberrecht verletzen soll, sondern dass dass das gewünschte, die gewünschte Eigenschaft der Datei war, dass sie ähm,
viel heruntergeladen wird. Und da entsteht natürlich auch ein ähm ein Modell für für Musiker über über mega Upload Geld zu verdienen. Das Problem, was ich da sehe, ist, dass irgendwie,
zumindest bei Marcels Artikel, den Artikel habe ich nicht zu Ende gelesen, äh nicht sehe, dass da mal ein Beispiel genannt wird,
Ja, also ist also die theoretische Möglichkeit ist sicherlich da gewesen. Ob das jetzt das der Hauptanwendungsfall von mega Upload war, äh lässt sich.
Bis jetzt nicht genau sagen, aber halte ich für eher unwahrscheinlich. Aber es wäre theoretisch möglich gewesen, dass ein Musiker seine eigenen, also auch,
von mir aus einer, der irgendwie bei Labels ist oder so, seine eigenen,
Platten dort hochlädt, die zur Verbreitung bringt, das irgendwie als Marketingmaßnahme sieht. Also es gibt ja eine Korrelation zwischen den Downloads und,
den Käufen eines Albums, die Kausalität dieser Korrelation ist ja ein bisschen unklar, ob das eine Drittvariable ist, das heißt, das Album ist einfach grundsätzlich beliebt oder ob vielleicht durch die Downloads
auch Käufe angekurbelt werden oder durch die Käufe downloads, also die Beziehung ist ja unklar, aber äh,
es hält sich ja auch die Argumentation, dass dieses Bewerben durch Downloads den Verkauf ankurbelt. Und das könnte also quasi ein Modell für Künstler gewesen sein, dass sie sagen, jetzt stelle ich das einfach selber rein, kassiere noch von mega die Punkte für diese Downloads,
Und ähm gleichzeitig kurbel ich den Verkauf an. Halte ich aber insgesamt für ein eher ähm.
Zu vernachlässigenden Faktor, in der Diskussion. Manuel könnte auch gleich die Verschwörungstheorie aufmachen, dass jetzt äh Universal deshalb so hinterher ist, um einen Konkurrenten auszuschalten.
Ja, ja, ja, genau. Ohne, ohne Frage. Also, das äh das die Theorie steht im Raum, ja.
Raum für Popcorn.
Ja, die Theorie steht im Raum. Haben wir es jetzt?
Super, Andre, vielen Dank für deinen äh ausführlichen Beitrag hier.
Vielen Dank für eure Einlad.
Auf jeden Fall sehr wertvoll. Linus und wir machen nächste Woche wieder weiter.
Wir machen nächste Woche wieder weiter.
Mit Lokbuchnetzpolitik. Und wir freuen uns auf euer Feedback und äh Kritik und Zuspruch, was auch immer ihr gerade so auf Lager habt und sagen tschüss und bis bald.
Tschau, tschau.